well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this extraordinary event I
think today it's wonderful to have you
all here and to be able to join in what
I think has been a great celebration -
two days in the company of two
remarkable people I think in your
lifetime you'll get to meet a number of
remarkable people if you're very very
lucky and people who have changed the
face of our art who have fate changed
the face of our culture who have added
indelibly to what we look at and see and
experience on screens television and in
our cultural life the two people who
have been so significant and that are
with us today Paula Wagner and Steven
Bochco so we welcome them very very
warmly
here's a little information just I think
we've all read the BIOS but I'll just do
some highlights that the taller is at an
alumni of CMU which is so wonderful and
in acting and is also a University
trustee and takes that role very
seriously and advances the university
wherever she is I was out in LA a couple
of times this year since I've been here
and she carries the flag for us in a
wonderful wonderful way and by doing
that it enhances the university it
Hans's you it enhances the reputation of
graduates and it brings and attracts
attention to us and it also helps with
funding and a whole lot of things so we
really thank her for that role as a
trustee paula has had a remarkable
career and I maybe will hear a bit of
that this afternoon but having started
as an actor she ends up in Los Angeles
as one of the first women appointed to
Creative Artists Agency as as an agent
one of the first women to do that which
is you know glass ceiling stuff and it's
very very very important that that's
happened she went on 13 years with Tom
Cruise producing major features
including Mission Impossible one two and
three and The Last Samurai so we've just
been upstairs watching a real of a
number of films that Paul has been
involved with and it's just utterly
remarkable what's what you've done and
it's just a huge credit to you Paul has
been honored as the first woman in
Hollywood icon award she served the
first-time directors jury at the venice
film festival and served as co-chair of
the hollywood film festival for many
years she's currently focused on
developing film and theater projects
including some with recent graduates
from CMU so I'm sure we'll hear more of
those things as the afternoon continues
Stephen is also an alum of CMU and
lovely to have him back after a little
time Stephens been a commencement
speaker at the University and his
groundbreaking television writing and
producing credits include Hill Street
Blues LA Law in YPD blue and they
altered the television landscape
I think forever I mean anyone who has
seen them knows that they are the
footprint by which people now trade in
television land and without Stevens
groundbreaking imaginative work we may
not be where we are now his awards
include the paddy Chayefsky Laurel award
for television to Writers Guild Awards
for Peabody Awards and for n-double-a-cp
Image Awards in 1976 Steven was inducted
into the Academy of Television Arts and
Sciences television Hall of Fame
Stephens been awarded honorary
doctorates from the American Film
Institute California Institute of the
Arts and Emerson College so it's with
great pleasure that I welcome both of
you today Don and I are going to share
the duties of questions and we hope to
get to you pretty quickly because I
think this is a great opportunity for
you to meet and talk with and exchange
ideas with two of the cultural leaders
of our time I maybe I'll just kick off
the first question to each which is
something along the lines of having been
so successful in the film industry and
television industries how did the
education that you had here and
elsewhere put you in the position that
you are today that you're now here as
two eminent people in the American
cultural scene what role did education
play in that for both of you for me it
was a much straighter path than it was
for Paul so it's it's easy for me and
obviously truthful for me to say that
that the education I got here both in
terms of writing and and theater in
general and being exposed to
I think I've said it several times in
some of our smaller sessions that the
best writing classes I had when I was
here for my acting classes I learned so
much about character and storytelling
structure my education as a writer was
invaluable but my my world education in
terms of learning about a community of
like-minded artists was probably the
singularly most important thing that I
took away from my years here on campus I
grew up here and I grew up here
notwithstanding how young I was but I
you know I started my artistic journey
here and I went into a medium in in the
1960s that was not considered an art
meeting it was a medium that that people
who worked in it were embarrassed to
admit that they worked in it and people
who watched it were a little embarrassed
to say that they watched it and and I
brought from my years here a sense of
art to what I did and it took 15 years
but I I think we began to do work in
television that we could all of us be
proud of as art and and and and that all
started from what I received here I I
think some very broad concepts came from
my education here and I definitively
look to the education I had a Carnegie
Mellon in the drama department as being
the foundation from my entire career
which is a very unusual career it was
it's it's
the career path I have taken is almost
as creative as the actual thing I've
been doing ah hum and I would say that
the discipline that you you learned is
invaluable disciplined performers
directors creators writers designers or
of it so believe it or not it's a rare
quality and you have it because you are
given that structure that is so
important that you internalize so I
would say the discipline the ideals the
classical training and background
believe it or not even now my training
in the history of the theater has held
me in good stead when I look to place
which is so an area that I'm working
more in now it's going back to the
theater my connections I don't want to
use the word can I want to say my my
networking the people my friends I made
friends here that are my dearest and
closest friends for life I met people I
met Steven Bochco here at Carnegie
Mellon and frankly he was a very
gracious professional when I knocked on
his door I don't know if you remember it
but I knocked on his door I said hi I'm
an actress from Carnegie Mellon come on
in and many other people that so the
people that you're with right now our
final importance to you in the future
you will help each other the professor's
the ambience and also the atmosphere
that I wasn't battling the dynamics of
being in New York or Los Angeles I had
Pittsburgh and the city was quite
different than which allowed me to focus
and to concentrate and most importantly
I learned how to learn so so much of my
education came after college when I was
thrown into the real world but learning
how to learn is a very important quality
that
I got from this school I bet this
audience will want to know about the
climate that we're all in now you know
and how things have changed that I teach
a business of acting course and as soon
as you know we say well this is true
pretty soon it's not true and
particularly for you Stephen that the
way that TV shows are getting on now
must be tricky and changed in the past
few years I mean you've got since the
writers strike I would think a big
change has happened the the pilot season
process is different you're you're
competing with the reality TV what do
you find that that would be important
for us to know about the changes now
technology changes short-term trends
change everybody's concerned about
reality television so mine but I
remember when news magazines populated
20 hours of programming a week something
like that 18 hours of programming a week
I remember when game shows were all the
rage you know things change things come
around again the constant for for for
you all and the constant for me is we
provide content and the way we provide
content doesn't fundamentally change as
I say technology sophisticate s-- makes
certain things easier for us there are
more networks now than they used to be
you know circumstances changed maybe
sometimes it's harder to break through
you know their audiences have options
for entertainment that they didn't have
20 25 years ago so we all have to sort
of compete with with all those those
options but we're artists you know and
our fundamental chore as artists is to
provide rich meaningful content for
whatever the outlet de jour is you know
things do change but but it's easy to
stay focused
you're both gatekeepers on an area that
most people in this room want to be part
of what do you look for when somebody
comes and knocks on that door of yours
and these are young people straight out
of here and they've got aspirations to
be in your world what what do you look
for what are the qualities that you want
presented as they step through the door
I look for and I meet actors writers
directors designers believe it or not
when I'm putting the film together I
look for an underlining lying commitment
to your purpose to the thing that you
are doing and that shows by your
attitude that you believe in yourself
and your craft or your art or whatever
you want to call it your project that
you are a believer and that you are
committed I look for people who have
ideas of their own who are creative who
are highly professional well trained I
always look at a resume and go theatre I
want to meet that person or not just any
it's been in theater anywhere anytime
but but a trained theatrical person
who's who has some background it's as
they say and from an actor stand but
it's in the eyes it's in the way you
carry yourself and they somehow your
sense of purpose about your art and your
craft and the work that you do
transcends any one moment the ability to
connect with the person you're dealing
with someone walks in a room and they
connect with me they somehow know what I
need and can can help me solve my
problem whether it's a casting problem
or I need a director where I'm looking
for a writer you you are able to channel
your energies yourself your your
impulses your thoughts into that moment
and somehow fulfill what my problem is
is the producer if you will or the
studio or the agent or whatever it is
you're able to fulfill my need at that
moment I need to cast this part I need
to get a writer and you carry yourself
with authenticity with dignity with with
with commitment and with a purpose and I
hope that's not too general but that is
really what I look for in someone and
it's just something you have and you
develop because there's a balance
between foot spa and genuinely genuinely
fin yourself isn't there and an artist
to survive I think has to ultimately
have can convinced themselves that they
are an artist and have something very
worthy to put forward pushing that
forward is a very fine balance for a
young artist coming out of here so how
much what spar do you need and how much
do you like
well uh not too much
I think III think a person your
personhood if as it were in addition to
your creative artist being but that you
are a human being and you let that show
I like people who have who aren't afraid
to show a certain vulnerability but who
also have a tough approach to life
professionally so yeah a little bit of
hoods but never hurt but what's being
defined as I remember it by the kid who
murders his mother and father and pleads
for mercy from the court on the grounds
that he's an orphan speaking of that
what about material I mean you started
to talk about the crossover ideas for
material that you might want to produce
what what speaks to you in that way you
know what do you want to work on I all
speak things that movie ideas I'd said
earlier to my class can come from any
place look at Hollywood now games barbie
the movie scrabble the movie yes they
are making monopoly the movie anywhere
you can get an idea as long as it
resonates and somehow has some cultural
resonance of some kind even the most you
know audacious big Hollywood movies that
work have some cultural resonance and
whether it's a great novel a play a song
a book TV show you look everywhere an
article in the newspaper use life as
your kind of your inspiration for your
ideas and then you figure out what
format whether maybe it's something that
goes to television or film
or a theater you know you you mold the
the idea to the tip to how it's done to
the platform that it's released upon do
you have anything new - well my process
is a lot different you know because I
generate you know I live in a pretty
small room and and I tend to generate my
own stuff so I always start there but
what I look for is is help you know and
a ghost or something
we we've all talked about over the last
two days in one way or another which is
collaboration I learned very early in my
career that a I'm not constitutionally
capable of being a one-man band and -
it's not productive you know in in the
context of the work that I do
collaboration is everything so I look
for I look for voices I look I look for
voices that fill out the course and and
that can be writers actors directors
producers designers you know and and and
as I've said in our smaller groups over
the last few days every one of you is
poised to be a consummate professional
because you're getting the best training
available any I think anywhere in
America really and so that's the you
know that's the small look at it the
bigger picture is
ditto what she said it just about how
one presents I mean what you want to
always do is get in the door
you don't want the person at the door
saying and no thank you no let's call me
another time then you've done something
wrong so all of those terrific words of
wisdom about presenting oneself in a
professional way in a focused way is
very important Packaging does have its
place in the entirety of all the things
you learn here what about making the
smooth transmission a transition from
the school into the profession because
these people are all working with next
to each other sitting out here in the
audience might be the next best
screenwriter there might be the next
playwright the next best Academy
award-winning actor what about putting
together teams while they're in this
sort of student setting what you're
about to work with some people Paul or
out in LA who are graduates from here
and you're developing work with them
would you like to just explain a bit
about that and what the advantages of
trying to find collaborations while
you're in a Academy like this that may
go on and bear fruit later well a lot of
film makers and production companies and
acting companies start at the university
level when I was at Carnegie and this
will bait me gonna just put it out there
Godspell was created I'm sure you all
have seen or talked to Stephen Schwartz
who was here you were kind of been on
the cusp at that time you think you were
leaving or here so collaboration is a
fantastic thing you are all talented
people you will all common interests
common grounds in which to communicate
and you you it's really important that
you appreciate your training your
background the fact that you were so
highly and selectively brought into this
school it's very competitive out there
and your training is top-notch Bar None
so look to your left and right and find
ways to collaborate I think it's
potentially very exciting you you have a
mission and you have a responsibility to
bring us the future because we are
sitting here on the threshold I'm
sitting here in the movie business going
along with all my colleagues in the
movie business going whoa wait a second
everything is in transition nothing is
what it was two years ago the DVD market
is forever changed the screen sizes have
changed technology has exploded the
economic crisis has certainly affected
Hollywood Hollywood is no longer a
little insular a little town in
California where you go and get
discovered by sitting on a barstool
Hollywood is a huge business huge
international imprint made by Hollywood
massive media conglomerates now own and
control every single studio so that
you're not just talking about Universal
Pictures you're talking about General
Electric NBC Universal Pictures so
you're talking about Sony owning a movie
company which is now called Sony so it's
a different world you have a big
corporate world out there looking at you
confronting you so your job is to be the
architects of change creatively bring us
the new ideas I like that I'm embracing
of that bring us the combining of the
technology and then theater and bring us
bring us all those things that you can
find ways to
utilize the internet nobody really knows
how to manipulate or handle or what its
position is going to be you be the ones
to utilize it and ultimately the thing
that counts the most is what it is you
do your content but how you use your
content is requires now as much thought
preparation and handling as that thing
you do your career is in a way your
career you understand what I mean we got
a little bit more on this on this
transition because you know this is the
this is the green house where people are
coming to learn about art and technique
and then there's going to be this step
that what leaves the green house and you
know starts to work so what would you
suggest in the word of in the way of
networking or preparation that people
get ready to make this transition god I
wish there was a formula I could give
you for that life would be so much
easier with and there isn't I mean all
the things that Paula has mentioned all
the things I've mentioned don't really
necessarily get you in the door right
away you do have to be aggressive you do
have to pursue every conceivable edge
you can find you know
however annoying it may be at any given
moment in time you have to call her you
have to call me you have to call John
have to have to have to you have to find
that little crack and your water you
have to find that little crack that lets
you flow downstream if you don't
you'll wind up doing something else in
life which for whatever it's worth is
not terrible so many people that that I
went to school with so many people that
Paulo went to school with are hugely
successful in fields that may not
necessarily have been suggested by their
course of study here at Tec but which
uniquely inform them and prepared them
for other things and you know those are
opportunities that you may not see today
but the world will present you with as
you move on in life but in terms of our
business everybody has a different story
to tell which is one of the reasons why
it's so much fun my story I've never
heard my story before I never heard
Paula story before ten years from now
those of you who stay the course will
have wonderful amazing surprising
stories to tell and I suppose the the
only piece of advice is be prepared for
the unexpected so that you can take
advantage with all the wonderful
training that you have of those moments
and time that will present themselves
for you to take advantage of because
there's a similarity between your
careers in a certain sense that you were
saying yesterday that you felt that
you'd done a very long apprenticeship
for 10 years or 12 years before you've
decided that you would break out and
make your own work away from a company
Porter you've changed from an acting
career through an agency to running a
major studio that's that's a long time
isn't it that a career unfolds and
opportunities appear being ready for the
opportunity witnessing the opportunities
sensing an opportunity
did you know these things were coming or
could you did either of you know that
opportunity was around the corner uh
when I was sitting right and one of
those actually it wasn't here it was
over Kresge sitting in the main stage
theater and I walked on it last night
and remembered though at that moment
when I played Adelaide in Guys and Dolls
or Cressida and Troilus and Cressida and
some of them or when we did a production
directed by Paul Draper of combining
words this was very avant-garde at that
time words of TS Eliot and EE Cummings
combined with Paul Draper was a noted
dancer so we tap danced to the words of
the great poets and the music was Jim
Morrison and the doors that was my
college education and I was sitting here
and I didn't have a clue a dream a
thought that one day I would go from
being a Shakespearean actress at the
Yale rep to an agent in Hollywood crazy
kind of transformation to a production
company at Paramount Pictures to a
studio running a studio to an
independent producer that journey was a
very unusual journey and nothing that
occurred specifically in my education
really prepared me for that but the the
basic tools that I spoke of earlier were
the things the stamina the fortitude the
feet I'm not going to give up I'm gonna
do something I'm gonna you know I'm
going to be in this business and I'm
going to find my way and it's going to
be creative and and I'm gonna play by
the rules until I've played by them so
well I can break them and take a lot of
risks and I found things along the way
that meant something to me like the
women's movement to be very honest I
became very
active in the late 70s because I felt
actresses needed to be looked at
differently and the roles needed to be
different and there had to be some way
to express the the the depth and the
strength of who actresses than they were
called actresses were and so I created a
piece of theater and I brought on people
I produced it essentially so I did the
very thing I became I started because I
was so dissatisfied with all the agents
I basically became my own agent I
learned about contracts I took the law
boards and learned all about law and
greeting contracts and analyzing them
I studied who the agents were who the
casting directors were I wanted to know
more about the audition process I knew
nothing about the business when I got
out of Carnegie Mellon it's not and nor
should I have become the business person
that I am now so there there are skills
that you pick up but the the tools to
learn those skills you learn here and
you have to work very hard but work
effectively as well at your craft and
your career you have to have talent of
course that is a given and you got to
have luck but you have to know what luck
is how to how to turn it to your
advantage how to discover it pull it
from the air and you have to have a real
business sense for yourself you have to
be your own business person no matter
how great an artist you are in this
climate in this world because it all is
the business of entertainment so you put
all those things together and you go on
this journey and do not be afraid to
change direction as much as you are
committed to the thing you are doing
don't be afraid to make a change if that
change presents itself to you and is a
good change and a positive change in
something that allows you and you to
that's what I did do you have any
general advice like this might be a very
specific person-to-person sort of
question but about where where it's
smart for people to start giving their
talents given their interest I mean we
naturally think about either New York or
Los Angeles and there are more choices
than that but do you have any particular
preference or ideas or guidance about
where it would be good to start or does
it matter well start by getting a job
any job you know because you got to pay
your rent and your electric bills and
all that stuff
networking contacts
you got to work as hard at getting a job
as of doing a job maybe even harder you
know I always felt that that doing the
job well that's what I was trained for
nobody trains for getting the job I mean
that that's a that's a very
idiosyncratic process that we all go
through but Paul is right when when she
says that you know Paul's got a real big
brain and and and clearly is somebody
who needs to be in control of her
environment which is a great thing
because she just somehow figured out a
way to learn all this stuff she didn't
know about the business so that she
could maximize her chances so in the
absence of actually having a job doing
what you love to do and are trained to
do there are so many ancillary parts of
the business that you can acquaint
yourself with so you work hard at
preparing so that I've said this before
I'm boring the out of myself but
well not anybody else you know so that
when that door just cracks a little bit
you've got your ducks in a row you're
ready to go you've educated yourself
about all kinds of things I mean you
wouldn't dream of going to have an
interview with somebody Paul Wagner
Steven Bochco John Wells or some casting
director or whatever without doing a
little homework about who that person is
what what what they've done in the past
what are their credentials you know so
you prepare yourself so that you can
walk in a door and not only present your
credentials but present your personality
you know you're capable of having a
conversation you're capable of
communicating an idea you know I think
probably the most important part of an
interview is arguably the first 90
seconds you know it's like it's like the
way you watch television you know you'd
you go on like this
and you're looking for something that'll
get your thumb off the trigger and and I
always created shows pilot episodes with
the idea that I had to get you to pause
for like three minutes if I could get
you to not pull the trigger on me for
three minutes I got you you know I think
it's the same in an interview people
have short attention spans they've got
more things to do in a day than they
have time for be prepared you know
I mean it's there's no formula for it as
you know but can ask both of you what
makes a good collaborator
I mean poorly you've worked with Tom
Cruise first as his agent for ten years
and then as a co-producer on a whole
series what makes him a great
collaborator to you I think I think a
collaboration is about consensus where
there is an agreement that's made
between two people five people ten
people fifty people thousands of people
where there is a the goal is a similar
goal the long-term goal we're gonna make
a great movie
how are we going to get there there are
agreements along the way good
collaboration is understanding what one
person does and allowing for another
person to do what it is they do movies
are traditionally supposed to be they in
aren't always a collaborative art form
you start with an idea it becomes a
screenplay your writer comes aboard
let's say the producers putting it
together then the director comes aboard
and elaborates upon that and your actors
come in and my association with Tom over
the years its first as an agent and then
producing partners and the studio was
always about mutual goals in filmmaking
and the ability of both of us to do very
different things it was not the actor
and but I was the the kind of architect
of the whole process the project the
producer if you will and balance that's
about it's a sense of balance it's it's
it's and if you can't collaborate with
someone then you shouldn't be working
with that person I would always say as a
producer my job as a producer
is to help the director fulfill his or
her vision of the film they're going to
make now that can translate into theater
or whatever else now if I don't believe
in the director's vision I won't work
with the director because I I don't want
often you know look no collaboration is
running on two or one track absolutely
no disagreement as a matter of fact if
you say to someone in my business how is
the film going and they say oh it's
beautiful we finish on time and
everybody smiles and we've had no
problems and it's just great we're under
budget we're gonna even come in early
you know we're gonna finish our shoot
early and everyone's happy all the time
and I talked to somebody like that and
that film came out it was the biggest
disaster ever because there was no
friction that's the artistic process
friction and disagreement and arguing
and and figuring out and changing things
you you can never change the process
that's why business and finance
scratch their head when they look at the
arts and try to figure it out and
sometimes want to make it into the shoe
business when in fact it can't be it's
art you are artists you are creative
people with creative thoughts so you you
so the collaborative process can be a by
head-butting
and it can be it can be any number of
dynamics as long as the the group of
people that come together to make art
whatever it is that help it to become
commerce or need commerce to support the
art that that process leads to something
it's one plus one is three in this world
sorry to tell you that but just really
quickly going back over what do you do
when you get out of school in my
business knowledge and information
nation or power you have the Internet
learn everything you can learn about
everybody about every studio making mood
movies there aren't many about the
players about the rules of the game the
game board the more you know the more
confident you become the sharper you are
the more I want to sit and talk to you
if you walk in my office and you know
what you're talking about and I can say
to you who runs who's the chairman of
Sony Pictures and you start talking
about you know what's going on with GE
and Comcast coming in and how what
percent they're gonna buy even if you're
an actor I like that you should know
your business may I give you an anecdote
and quick just a little anecdote a young
man got out of college and he wants to
be a film producer and he came to me to
apply for a job as an assistant and I
will promote people they started as an
assistant I will bring them along and
then some of the people that have
started my assistants have become
producers he came in very smart sharp he
knew all about me he had it all down he
had worked at CAA for a while so he had
some agency skills and I said so I said
let's talk about the studios because I
need you to have knowledge who runs
Universal who's the chair of Universal
course that's always changing but you
know or who's this or what's that he
didn't know and I said thank you very
much you're very bright nice young man I
can't use you're not experienced enough
you don't know these people
so I came back from Christmas vacation
there was a plastic bag and a letter on
my desk and the letter said I really
want this job I'm sure cutting it I
really want this job I think I could
bring a lot to the job for you I know
what you need in terms of handling
phones and this and that the one area
that I that I obviously was not as
educated on were the players at the
various studios so I spent my Christmas
vacation learning and study them I did
flashcards for myself here's the cards
I'd like to come in would you quiz me he
sent me cards like pink quiz fox and
every position like a hundred employees
at every position he'd memorized all of
them what they did what their titles
were where their offices was everything
and that was like pink cards on one side
was the position in the description and
the other was the name and then
universal in all the studios so I said
okay let's see what this I call him in
man he knew everything I said okay
paramount pictures co-chair Brad gray
it's right great he knew everything I
gave him the job
yeah just so you can apply that metaphor
if you will to what all of these
businesses I think I think all of the
businesses like that kind of ingenuity
we might move to some questions but if I
could just ask Steven on that same line
you you've had actors and you've made
fortunes for them what what keeps an act
of fresh for you and what's the
relationship that collaboration for
somebody's in a long-running series you
stick with people for what reasons they
don't insult my mother you know that
always helps you know when I left here I
left with with an invisible network of
ensemble players and every opportunity
in my career as it progressed that I got
I reached out to my actor friends from
from Carnegie and we worked together all
the time and you know it's such a
subjective process but and I loved them
all but some of them you know George
Orwell in animal form said all animals
are equal and some animals are more
equal and and not to equate actors with
animals you guys but you know I just
connected with some actors differently
more intimately than I did with others
and over the years we just kept orbiting
each other and and when I finally got in
a position where I could really do
something with this core group of actors
and writers and you know and directors I
did
I mean Hill Street Blues was Charlie
hade Bruce White's or a Boston
mark frost came and and was writer with
us I'm probably leaving out a whole
bunch of folks you know from from
Carnegie I would work with Michael
Tucker oh my god might new yet Mikey's
my best friend okay thank you I would
work with them all tomorrow if I could
its it you know it just has to do with
shared vision you know when you're
talking about how do you collaborate
there's an interesting and I'll make
this quick there's there's an
interesting counterintuitive thing about
collaboration because most of us didn't
go into this business to be you know in
the third row of the course most of us
if not all of us have a fantasy about
being a star I didn't become a star
until I learned how to collaborate and
that's the counterintuitive part of it
that it's that it's the ability to
collaborate with your friends your peers
your colleagues that creates an
environment in which the sum is greater
than its parts and in that environment
people become stars as a as an
unintended consequence you know stardom
as an accident all the rest of it is
deliberate
you